gasp wait are we about to do a rant or
I'm confused it's grace
welcome to the brand-new YouTube channel
it's grace that should look amazingly
familiar to you I'm here now on this
channel I moved it happens I moved to
Los Angeles I just moved again how do I
begin to say all of the things that are
in my head I shouldn't say a lot of the
things that are in my head that glove
I'm like Hamburger Helper how does he do
Gogh I know how Cheers
yep sorry no one actually Cheers is each
other into the face here Cheers
that was your glass not your genitals
goose you want to say hello say its face
yeah you said it with your eyes here we
are
oh girl its grace Channel let's talk
business for two seconds cuz you're
probably all like duck a lot of people
have already said this online and you
probably already know this but if you do
not know this here's this feel I had a
contract with a company called My Damn
Channel comm and the contract came to an
end and both parties are moving forward
in different aspects of life and that is
all we were talk about that
now doesn't matter because what you know
and it shouldn't feel weird because it's
all the same stuff you've grown to
tolerate this gross shirt I don't play
softball you winged black eyeliner this
eye looks like there was an earthquake
happening when I tried to put that on
terrible unflattering lighting bodily
functions oh there's a lot today there's
a lot it's a lot it's a lot is it a lot
I don't there are other things in the
world that like Obama deals with a lot
grace shut oh this is here now second
and second most I need you just say
thank you to the YouTube community
you are as philosophers have put it um
tits in the mouth you guys are great
okay I'm gonna get sincere and look
here's sincere music to prove how
sincere I am right now
I had a sincere moment last night where
I just hit me all of the support that
the YouTube community had all the people
that have submitted these gasps videos
for the beginning this video all the
people that have mentioned the new
channel all the people that are like
championing this like new independent
world that I'm trying to live in ah I'm
bad with emotions and I'm terrible to
asking for help and you guys just
unwillingly no that's not willingly
completely willingly unwittingly who
would know English is my first language
you guys just voluntarily supported this
whole thing and I couldn't be more
grateful and to every person that
watches this and I read all of your
Tumblr posts and I see all of it and you
guys are so the feels stop someone
called dr. I got a case of the feels I
was so nervous about everything that was
happening and ah [ __ ] you guys right in
the butt the heart of the but another
question might be what can we expect at
this new it's grace channel you can
expect me I've been making a video for
you guys Monday through Friday it's
gonna be something that you're used to
but there might be some new spins on
some things and it will be really fun
and the thing is we're here to have fun
right
Yolo I can you and get the phrase out of
my mouth to say it uh hola I'm so
excited for this guys and I hope you are
too
and woot-woot who's on board the stupid
train woot is not the noise a train
makes a train goes choo choo but it
doesn't really go to either it goes
ah no that's a dial-up system have I
ever really been on a train I don't know
that's a new way way under videos you
guys for now I don't know I don't know
what's happening cuz who really does
know no one goes all I know is I should
probably get some new lights it's great
that's